so i was in the park last sunday and i
saw a bit of a commotion muslims
screaming shouting and i believe some
behavior was childish uh coming from the
muslims so i went there to correct the
brothers and say look guys let's
let's not behave that's because this
it's not really our you know uh in that
context and when i went and i heard
these a couple of christians there
calling the prophet peace be upon him a
pedophile
and i thought like these these guys have
the glass to talk so when i got there
uh and all praises belong to allah they
got a little bit uncomfortable yeah
because they were speaking to some
muslims
they didn't really know what was
happening so when i when i came there
and tried to
discuss with them and put them in their
place and actually one of them actually
agreed
and at this very moment of time you can
see he says it with his own love we say
why did the prophet wait
from the age of six to nine uh to
consummate the marriage why did he wait
and here's
he says it with his own mouth listen to
this guy so he says that
because he was waiting for her to become
an adult and that's
exactly our point
oh
what did i say what did i say they
didn't agree with
until she reached me when a woman would
start menstruating
she was classed as an adult so that's
what i meant when she she was a
nine-year-old adult the prophet peace be
upon him married and we've done many
videos which you can see on the screen
about this but however i came there
these two guys after a while
they decided to get out there because uh
they realized what was about to happen
and this is exactly what happened so
watch this video and then watch the
video where i speak to a christian guy
called captain
um and then when we turn the tables
around and talk about jesus the god of
the old testament
legislating some pretty mad stuff man
check this out guys watch it
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the 90s
okay captain hear me out was jesus the
god of the old testament who said get
babies and questions
yes yes in context of what you cannot
take out of context what
crushing babies are hunting right right
those same babies
yeah both same people i'm sorry
you
is
the house is ransacked and the woman
raped half of the city will go into
exile why
what did the mother call
is
is
is
which one is
is
in the old testament
oh